hello here you are once again you've
clicked on my face once more which means
i have not yet bored you for that i am
thankful and as usual before we get
started if you want to thank the sponsor
of this video we have ourselves a new
sponsor here this video is brought to
you by true build truebill is an
all-in-one personal finance platform
that helps you save more and spend less
it helps you manage your subscriptions
lower your bills monitor your credit
score and build your savings all in one
place it safely and securely monitors
your subscriptions and you can cancel
those subscriptions with just one click
cause we've all been there maybe you
signed up for the free trial period and
just forgot about it true bill will
sniff that out and be like hey you still
pay for this you want to cancel it you
can also set up a budget that'll show
you what you're spending by category
it'll give you notifications when you
exceed that budget you know gives you a
visual representation of where your
money's going this in a world where
we're all adulting credit score money
management it's all very important stuff
try it out for free go to truebill.com
john's or click the link below you might
be surprised at what you're paying for
that you forgot you were paying for that
you haven't used for like two
presidential terms thank you once again
to truebill for sponsoring this video i
do appreciate it and now i rip myself
away from the final fantasy 6 pixel
remastered remaster i've been looking
forward to for
quite some time and i do it to talk
about garbage why
because that could be fun too i guess
[Music]
so texas chainsaw massacre is a sequel
to the texas chainsaw massacre
sans
and it's one of those movies that's a
new sequel that rat cons everything
except the original movie so retcons all
the other sequels which i'm pretty sure
was exactly what that movie texas
chainsaw 3d did because if at first you
don't succeed keep making garbage the
rule of hollywood this is the worst
mulligan ever it literally feels like
you only have two lanes all right
mulligan and now i have one land i
how did i get worse that's what this
movie feels like to be fair i haven't
seen texas chainsaw 3d since it was in
theaters i saw it the once which is
probably how often i'm going to watch
texas chainsaw massacre so getting into
the plot of this movie after i've just
bitched about it for this long there's a
group of young people these young
entrepreneurial types these gen zers who
all go to this ghost town they're like
hey
we'll buy it and auction it off and
bring life into it i guess or create a
cult compound somewhere in the middle of
nowhere i don't know the point is that's
what they want to do turns out
leatherface is there and he gets really
pissed then something else happens in
the movie that really makes leatherface
mad now leatherface goes on his killing
spring up against a bunch of characters
you don't care about so you're kind of
rooting for leatherface to kill people
and in that this movie does have a
couple scenes where i was like oh that's
a nice bloodbath let's do it the blood
the slaughter you know you're kind of
there at that point and that can work
i've experienced movies where i was like
yeah i'm just kind of rooting for the
bad guy to kill people that's fine
that's what happens when i watch final
destination movies i'm waiting for this
fatalistic death just to weed these
people out or saw i'm like
you go jigsaw that's why i'm here like
example there's a scene in a bus where
just this massacre is happening you're
like okay i could kind of get into this
your lizard brain kicks on you're like
sure it's just oozing and dripping with
carnage good enough right but then that
other part of your brain kicks on that
average [ __ ] human being brain kicks
on and you're like wait wait wait wait
because leatherface has the most silent
chainsaw ever in this movie yeah the
cool thing about leatherface or
chainsaws in general in movies when
they're used as massacre equipment is
that they have that
that rumble sound and you know it's
coming after you it's scary you're like
oh [ __ ] gotta be quiet gotta be quieter
than the chainsaw in this movie when
it's idle because it makes no sound
whatsoever it just goes from nothing
silent to
so silent in fact that when the chainsaw
is on but idle people are trying to
creep away like we gotta open this
window it's all leather faces like what
was that that i just heard over my idle
chainsaw that's making no sound on
screen it wasn't an electric chainsaw it
did make
idle gas-powered sounds intermittently
throughout the movie just sometimes it
made it sometimes it didn't you know
when making this movie someone was like
how would leatherface hear the slight
window creak open over the chainsaw do
you think anyone's gonna notice that no
not at all it's only the internet and
social media no one's gonna catch that
and point it out
forever well i wouldn't say forever
because no one's gonna remember this
movie no that's not the writing i'm not
writing it up yet i'm still going i have
things to say you want to talk about
unrealistic there's a scene in this
movie where someone gets
straight up to someone gets the chainsaw
the full brunt of it someone gets the
mkx through the gut lifted into the air
it just
revs the chainsaw ass and blood just
falling on leatherface and then later on
far after this person should have died
because they should have died right then
and there the person's alive long enough
to pop a shot at leatherface then dies i
was like well it's official texas
chainsaw massacre is
it's a ghost movie because that person
was not [ __ ] alive the big thing this
movie does it takes inspiration from the
2018 halloween movie you know 2018
halloween movie was the sequel that was
a retcon of all the other sequels
retconned everything except the original
movie and it had the survivor of the
original movie come back to face the
monster and that's what this movie does
it has the character sally the survivor
of the original texas chainsaw massacre
movie to come and face the monster in a
way that's just anti-climactic and sucks
lurie strode in 2018 halloween she's the
main point this movie sally just kind of
seems like an afterthought thrown into
this movie briefly and for no reason
whatsoever like if she wasn't in the
movie at all movie would be no different
i really mean that actually that's
really sad when you say it out loud
but that's true she wasn't in the movie
the movie just wouldn't change at all
except for like one scene where she
comes in she's like run at a point the
movie ends with zero payoff whatsoever
and [ __ ] go okay i watched that could
have done anything else with my time
that's really why i'm doing this video
because i watched it i was like [ __ ] if
i'm not making a video about this i'm
getting that time back plus i'm spending
more time talking about it but you know
i'll at least use my experience watching
this movie to keep the channel machine
turning there's no way i wasn't going to
talk about this movie i have to make it
worth it somehow and if for nothing else
i'm letting you know
you definitely shouldn't you should not
that makes it all worth it my friends
use my pain to your advantage oh god i
forgot about this
but i have to touch on i have to talk
about it because it's in the movie again
for no real reason now this could have
worked out they could have used this for
something in the movie they just don't
there's these brief flashback moments in
this movie like really brief you know at
the end of joker where joker's sitting
there and he goes i just thought of a
joke and it really briefly shows bruce
wayne and his dead parents the flashback
scenes are that quick but they're there
to show you that at least one of the
characters in this movie is a survivor
of a school shooting
yeah it's in here for character
development i guess
doesn't really lead to anything
it's just kind of there at best it's
really awkward at worst it's just
another part of texas jade's on massacre
in the end texas chainsaw massagers it's
proof that they should just stop trying
to do this i feel like texas chainsaw
massacres kind of like terminator
someone out there has it in their mind
where they're like no no this is a
franchise we should really keep going
with this it's like nah i think the best
years are behind us
just let it go i have come to tell you
that texas chainsaw massacre it sawed
off dog [ __ ] sorry i was out of town on
vacay relaxing would have gotten you
this video last weekend um but i didn't
to anyone who saw this movie because i
didn't forewarn you about it i really do
apologize uh most sincere youtuber
apology ever all right so texas chainsaw
massacre have you seen it what did you
think about it again if you did i'm
sorry whatever you thought comment below
let me know and as always if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more
[Music]
you